Bitcoin is such a complex topic
everybody's trying to understand it and
I just don't think there's enough
information out there the information
that's currently out there really
Technical and I just think that becomes
such a barrier to entry for so many
young people that want to get involved
you know even women I'm not particularly
like a feminist or anything like that
but you know women I think should have
their own money I think they should have
Financial Freedom and they're not going
to pick up some like fat heavy technical
book written by you know some nerd or
whatever so I wanted to create something
which was you know appealing exciting
that gave like a whole another
demographic access to this technology